[Musica]
vi racconto una storia che ha luogo in
un giorno di pioggia a quanti di voi
sarà capitato in un giorno di pioggia di
stare sul divano insieme ad amici a
guardare una partita di pallone magari
una partita in bilico fino all'ultimo
tensione suspense ma ricordiamoci che
fuori piove piove tanto tanto magari
tanto da far accadere questo accidenti
magari proprio così quando la squadra
del cuore stava proprio battendo il
classico calcio di rigore al novantesimo
questo un problema questo è un problema
sgradevole è chiaro per un problema al
quale io sono particolarmente
affezionato è un problema
come dire che mi ha cambiato la vita è
un problema che mi piace perché ha
portato ad una soluzione anzi è un
problema che contiene in sé una
soluzione ma su questo torniamo dopo
diciamo che questo problema è l'inizio
della storia che racconta oggi è una
storia che ha luogo qui a genova in un
giorno di pioggia appunto un triste
giorno di pioggia
questo l'alluvione del 2011
un'alluvione che ha messo letteralmente
in ginocchio questa città la superba
come l'ha definita da petrarca ma il
problema delle alluvioni non è un
problema di genova è un problema che sta
martoriando l'intero nostro pianeta
veramente distruggendo un sacco di vite
e creando un sacco di danni
è un problema che riguarda l'europa
questa immagine ricordate tutti riguarda
l'america riguarda l'asia riguarda
l'australia riguarda il mondo intero il
nemico della mia storia
si chiama bomba d'acqua penso che anche
questo lo conoscete tutti
e questo fenomeno piovoso che in questi
ultimi anni sta distruggendo i nostri
territori in maniera sempre più
frequente e intensa ma lo vedete a
qualcosa che si localizza accidenti a
piccolo si scarica in un veramente in un
luogo piccolissimo in un attimo e
guardate che intensità che ha
così densa l'acqua che vediamo in una
bomba d'acqua
questo è un fenomeno che ha delle
conseguenze immediate localizzate e
devastanti vi rendete conto di quanto in
questo contesto i fattori spazio e tempo
siano determinanti
quando si combatte una battaglia è
meglio conoscere il proprio nemico
conoscere per conoscerlo per
l'anticipare alle sue mosse piuttosto
che per poterle comunque gestire e
quando si ha a che fare con un nemico di
questo tipo è dura si muove veloce è
piccolo si scarica in un punto molto
localizzato con grande intensità è una
bomba
si chiama bomba d'acqua amica a caso
viene chiamata così è purtroppo le
autorità territoriali non hanno a
disposizione la strumentazione adeguata
a localizzare in maniera precisa e
seguire in maniera continua quantificare
bene queste piogge e quindi in buona
sostanza non abbiamo le armi adeguate
per combattere questa battaglia
abbiamo dei pluviometri in sostanza sono
dei secchi che prendono e misurano
quello che cade sulla loro testa lo
fanno bene sono gli unici strumenti che
possono dire di misurare veramente
quello che piove in quel punto ma in
quel punto non da altre parti
tecnicamente vedete sono disposti in
maniera sparsa sul territorio a km l'uno
dall'altro e quando passa una bomba
d'acqua bella stretta spesso ci passa
pure in mezzo e manco si vede se non
abbiamo anche i radar e radar meteo sono
degli oggetti che sostanzialmente fanno
una scansione a 360 gradi dell'acqua che
sta intorno a loro però intrinsecamente
hanno dei problemi rispetto a questa
nostra caccia alla bomba d'acqua perché
sono oggetti che lavorano su grandi
distanze e quando si lavora su grandi
distanze siano dei problemi di
risoluzione
pensate alla macchina fotografica faccio
una foto qui vicino e vedo tutti i
dettagli e comincia ad andare avanti con
l'obiettivo della giu lontano i dettagli
li perdo e quando devo prendere una cosa
che grossa pochi chilometri bene questo
è un problema ma non dimentichiamoci che
il problema è anche il fattore tempo
abbiamo poco tempo una bomba d'acqua far
esondare un fiume
o crollare una strada in pochissimi
minuti un radar giusto per darvi un'idea
ci mette circa 10 minuti a fare la sua
scansione e poi il dato viene viene
trasmesso viene elaborato interpretato
validato eccetera il tempo passa il
fiume gonfia gonfia gonfia e non aspetta
certo noi ci rendiamo bene conto che in
questo modo noi stiamo offrendo il
fianco al nostro nemico bene tornando a
noi abbiamo appunto un nemico non
abbiamo le armi per combattere questa
battaglia ci vuole una soluzione
dopo il 4 novembre 2011 in alcuni tavoli
di lavoro emerge emerge chiaramente che
questa questo nemico le bombe d'acqua
vanno monitorate in maniera diversa dal
solito vanno monitorate in maniera più
continua con una finezza spaziale
maggiore è sempre in tempo reale vanno
quantificate
ed emerge altrettanto chiaramente che
gli strumenti come veniamo di dire non
sono gli strumenti usati ad oggi non
sono adeguati a fare questo tipo di
lavoro
bene ci viene chiesto a me e ad alcuni
colleghi che siamo quelle rinnovazione
della i siti io ne vengono il mondo
delle telecomunicazioni dell'informatica
ci viene chiesto se ci venisse in mente
qualcosa che potesse effettivamente
localizzare in maniera fine e
quantificare in tempo reale la pioggia
che cade sul territorio bene noi ci
abbiamo pensato e in effetti abbiamo
detto ma forse la soluzione la
conosciamo già bene tutti ricorderete la
storia del rigore al novantesimo quando
piove forte il segnale della televisione
satellitare viene indebolito e la
letteratura delle telecomunicazioni ci
dice anche come e quanto viene
indebolito e quindi basta invertire il
punto di vista è quello che è un dato
l'indebolimento di attenuazione mi
diventa un dato di pioggia ricordate
quando all'inizio dicevo che la
soluzione stava nel
beh qui più o meno il problema contiene
una soluzione a un altro problema ma sta
proprio lì il gioco basta astrarsi un
attimo non ci si astrae un po e ci si
rende conto di avere già a disposizione
una miriade di strumenti magari nati per
uno scopo che possono essere utilizzati
per altro bene però quando parlo di
segnale televisivo satellitare
sto parlando di cosa proprio quello
quello che viene ricevuto dalle antenne
paraboliche che abbiamo tutti sul tetto
dalle nostre case né più né meno quello
il permetto di fare una breve
divagazione tecnica i satelliti che
trasmettono la televisione commerciale
sono una miriade sono tantissimi tutti
sull'orbita equatoriale
praticamente se noi guardiamo verso sud
e alziamo lo sguardo ne vediamo uno ogni
grado
vediamo si fa per dire perché sono
36.000 chilometri di altezza quindi non
li vediamo ma sono lì quello trasmette
la tv italiana quello anche quello turca
greca spagnola eccetera eccetera
eccetera in una città io guardo quello
lo vedo bene nello punto il mio vicino
che anche lui guarda la tv italiana me
non può guardare quello sequestratogli
dell'iper che ha di fronte un palazzo
punto all'altro satellite che trasmette
la televisione italiana poi c'è il
vicino turco che appunto si guarda la
sua televisione turca sull'altro
satellite quello spagnolo che si guarda
la televisione sul suo satellite
spagnolo ecco quindi tutte queste
antenne sono puntate su diversi
satelliti e questa è una
rappresentazione di quello che abbiamo
nelle nostre città tante antenne che
puntano a tanti satelliti
se prendiamo quindi tutti questi diciamo
raggi disegnati in questa slide quindi
tutte queste misurazioni che possono
essere date dalle tante antenne
otteniamo effettivamente una maglia
molto molto fitta di dati pluviometrici
quindi è una rappresentazione
estremamente raffinata della pioggia che
può cadere su un territorio e peraltro
ce l'abbiamo in tempo reale perché la
televisione ci arriva in continua non è
che ci arriva ogni tanto e quindi quel
segnale noi lo possiamo osservare ogni
quanto vogliamo
questo è quello che diamo queste sono
delle mappe pluviometriche assolutamente
innovative che cambiano in continuo e
che rappresentano in maniera molto fine
la pioggia che cade sul territorio
queste sono utili a chi deve intervenire
sul territorio per poter gestire le
proprie risorse nei momenti di emergenza
cosa intendo dire nel pratico questa è
una zona nel levante genovese che
monitoriamo col nostro sistema dove c'è
la linea rossa abbiamo un crinale alla
sinistra la destra in giallo in
arancione abbiamo due bacini ci capita
spesso ma nel raggio diciamo una
lunghezza lineare di 5 km di vedere che
da una parte piove di più
dall'altra piove di meno a volte da una
parte piove dall'altra manco e quando
c'è un'emergenza e si hanno poche
risorse
io risorse intendo protezione civile
volontari vigili del fuoco polizia
municipale eccetera e meglio saperle
focalizzare e concentrare dove serve
se da una parte sta piovendo dall'altra
no e bene che si mandino dove sta
piovendo di più o comunque che si
razionalizzino in maniera mirata questo
non può avvenire se non si conosce bene
il contesto pluviometrico del territorio
a quel punto si tende a spargere sul
territorio le risorse ma poi capita che
dove c'è una pattuglia non succede
niente dove non c'era una pattuglia
invece avvenga al disastro ecco questo
serve alle autorità proprio per poter
gestire le emergenze
magari si evitano cose di questo tipo
persone che camminano che guidano in
zone potenzialmente inondabili ho già
inondate ma questa non è una cosa che
non succede mai
a genova purtroppo lo abbiamo visto più
volte e tutte le volte la gente in giro
magari aver potuto concentrare lì
qualcuno che chiudeva la zona magari si
può dire agli esercenti di alzare le
barriere di alzare i materiali che hanno
dentro le merci per evitare che si
bagnino ma anche in altri contesti
pensiamo alla mobilità miss emilia mai
capitato di un'autostrada di entrare in
una galleria dove non piove o piove poco
uscire dalla galleria quindi poche
centinaia di metri più in là un
chilometro massimo e trovare una
fortissima pioggia magari in cura
così anche un pochino più pericoloso pro
capite è capitato ecco quanto sarebbe
importante pur nel raggio di poche
centinaia di metri dire attenzione in
uscita dalla galleria piove forte
queste sono informazioni comunque utili
anche tutti i giorni pensiamo anche la
logistica aeroportuale disagio o blocchi
addirittura causati dal forte maltempo
piuttosto che ai cantieri in alveo che
sono sostanzialmente cantieri che spesso
sono addirittura li proprio perché ci
sono torrenti e fiumi che sono a rischio
esondazione vanno sanati eccetera
eccetera
li abbiamo non tanto le persone che
lavorano nei momenti di forti piogge che
tendenzialmente non si lavora in quei
momenti ma dei macchinari comunque
particolarmente grossi costosi che
possono essere spostati eccetera
comunque gestito meglio il cantiere ma
anche altri contesti
pensiamo veramente che siamo tutti tutti
sono all'interno del problema
dell'alluvione un allevamento che magari
in una zona inondabile se si sa
effettivamente che sta riversando su una
bomba d'acqua su quella zona si può
spostare questa madre magari non subire
dei danni è uno dei tanti esempi
sostanzialmente questo sistema è un
sistema di supporto alla decisione
supporto alla decisione perché da dei
dati che prima non c'erano in tempo
reale altamente capillari peraltro
basandosi sull'utilizzo sul riutilizzo e
l'adattamento di tecnologie
infrastrutture esistenti ha la
possibilità di minimizzare i costi e
questo è molto importante
su questa tecnologia noi possiamo
ottenere andare sulla strada di
obiettivi importanti territori
resilienti che sono in ginocchio si per
quello che hanno subito ma che si rialza
non hanno le gambe spezzate attività
preparate l'attività economica sa che
sta arrivando qualcosa sta al rischio
che corre e quindi misure preventive
alzo la merce metto le barriere eccetera
e in fondo persone più sicure in fondo
non e non in ordine di importanza per
questa tecnologia la comunità europea ci
ha riconosciuto e ci ha detto che il
nostro progetto è uno dei più innovativi
al mondo e ci ha riconosciuto un
cofinanziamento per sviluppare su questa
tecnologia un sistema innovativo di
allerta precoce
noi siamo orgogliosi molto
di questo riconoscimento ma non si può
rimanere sulla carta sugli attestati
l'innovazione va sperimentata
l'innovazione va messa in campo bisogna
dimostrare come funziona bisogna vederne
le criticità perché ci sono sempre
bisogna superarle e dimostrare che
l'innovazione può diventare un bene per
tutti noi siamo su questa strada abbiamo
diverse installazioni in liguria in
toscana e il lazio nelle alpi francesi
abbiamo entry municipalità che hanno già
creduto in questo progetto abbiamo
municipalità che tutti i giorni con
queste mappe
seguono un contesto più via metrico in
maniera continua nel loro territorio e
fanno delle scelte scelgono in base a un
contesto questa volta conosciuto un
passaggio molto importante che può
portare a dei buoni risultati in termini
di salvaguardia della vita e dei beni ma
possiamo guardare oltre avete idea di
quante antenne ci sono in giro per le
città sicuramente visiva si ma sono più
di 10 milioni in italia
pensate che il 50 per cento delle
persone in inghilterra guarda la
televisione via satellite il 43 per
cento in germania il 36 in italia e così
via ce n'è una miriade e se potessimo
usare le antenne di tutti potremo andare
veramente oltre a guardare in alto come
stiamo dicendo oggi perché conoscendo in
maniera dettagliata al contesto
pluviometrico e la storia pluviometrica
continua in un territorio possiamo
conoscere anche statisticamente come si
comportano questi fenomeni con un
approccio nuovo diverso e magari quando
quando arriva la bomba d'acqua magari
cominciare anche a dire ma forse posso
prevedere il comportamento breve termine
posso anche prevedere cosa farà quali
sono le conseguenze
esonda il fiume fra un'ora in quel punto
franerà una strada fra due in quell
altro punto sono obiettivi veramente
importanti molto importanti ma per far
questo entrata in gioco voi
entriamo in gioco tutti vi ricordate
quando dicevano inizio nuovamente che la
soluzione sta nel problema in questo
caso un problema di ognuno di noi
se condiviso può diventare una soluzione
per ognuno di noi basta veramente una
piccola aggiunta
al software dei decoder che tutti noi
abbiamo a casa per trasformare ogni
nostra antenna in un sensore di pioggia
e partecipare alla sicurezza di tutti
questo per far sì che la storia che ho
raccontato oggi che ha luogo in un
giorno di pioggia
un triste giorno di pioggia possa avere
un lieto fine e che tutti noi possiamo
tornare a sorridere
nei giorni di pioggia
[Applauso]